yeah welcome to this video yet another
blitz video and play a form for change
and 96 yeah that's probably not nothing
but at night f3 and this is so ok that's
a bit strange not quite sure what black
is aiming for now we got a French with
them somewhat strange showpiece
placement with black not being able to
play c5 ok this is the IDM he wants to
wants to get in that b6 and long castles
quickly so yeah what is my general idea
i can try to play for an f4 f5 i can
also just probably just a complete
development rookie one free pass tonight
f1 g3 something like this i'd i'd like
to to do something on the queenside if
he cancels long but first he should
cancel long before i play before
alright so night 2 g-3 are not sure this
night can be very useful on the on the
queenside as well okay I'll play a
little till you waiting move him I want
to play before word only if he castles
long really he could switch back to
short castle then those moves are bit of
a non-issue they didn't do much III and
Ruby one but also didn't didn't hurt and
if he cancels long than before and
everything's is fine I'd like for
instance play long castles before and
then night to be three on b3 it would
always cover c5 so that never can play
c5 and they have those ideas of my to to
see five then yeah exactly this before
night be 395 this is a very typical way
to play this all right so he's some
preparing f6 it seems so let's let's go
here on on let's let's let's just think
him a bit if he plays f6 I I have Bishop
f4 as a as an answer I can also play
Knight b3f 6b five so that GM yeah this
looks rather good actually okay come on
this this is good here because 95 is is
an idea this I cannot sacrifice
it would open up the beef island and
give me some some nice attack if
everything else is co-ordinated of
course I cannot just simply a sacrifice
this piece this is some interesting well
g4 is not really an option for him I
mean not quite sure what this is doing
okay I can go for a4 a5 also i'm really
not sure what this move is doing I mean
g4 I can just retreat I even play Knight
edge form yeah okay g4 yeah I can just
just retreat just really it doesn't
really matter okay what it does is dumb
it gives him some square only seven
buddy okay a 5-4 sir on the agenda
anyway and it take okay about the clock
time of course and spend them quite some
time on this the questions should i play
night everyone lied f1 III or is this
night better place them potentially on
b3 later so that i don't really need to
play that f1 okay Oh interesting okay
I don't want to spend so much time
really okay I don't really mind to
exchange this okay the rook has some
potentially good on da phone doesn't do
much on b1 this 95 it's not really an
option anymore after he shows his
intention to move the king so be five
Andruw k7 is this sir this is a
possibility all right and this is also
an idea just taking one f5 and 93 to f4
okay he allows this so yeah I'm
preventing 96 for the moment now i'm
taking d5 also f5 is also week the so
look so yeah basically lost for black i
cannot really see how he defends all
those weak spots and bad pieces yeah
okay can can um h3 just g3 and g3 that's
just a ch3 so there is simply no attack
and a five is not defensible and h3 so
all nicely covered can go look at to h4
but simply this one and next move 495
yeah I thought Queen takes f five would
be puzzle night f4 okay for this was the
phone ok I hope this doesn't blunder
piece then the guy on the other end is
uh is guilty of spoiling my game so g3
you're saying ok ok let's just bring the
rook back and put it here this is so
simple but I think sufficient grab the
material and and run he still has got a
bad Bishop and bad King 96 I could have
played ok but this is so this is rather
easy now d 5 and then I pick up before I
could have taken immediately even jack
Jack Black resign you know yeah I think
um you can play like this yeah i mean
it's it's not super terrible but it's
rather passive for black coming this way
so white simply has a very nice space
advantage and it's not clear where
blacks counter place is coming from if
you look at this and would you would
just um think of this as a mirror image
of Kings Indian yeah with the before
being g4 in the King's engineer like has
quad castle wrong but you would Castle
shorten the Kings Indian I would have to
fianchetto with g6 and Bishop g7 it's
just the same luck here and black has
never got f5 this would be c5 in this
position and I mean where exactly is
blacks play if he cannot play a c5 the
only kind of players f6 but this always
we just Ricans on the e-file so black is
just condemned to a sit and wait
position more or less yeah alright
thanks for watching